welcome professor Sophie Scott welcome
to Scandinavia why do we laugh well we
think we love because of jokes if you
ask people about laughter they'll talk
about jokes and humor and comedy but if
you look at people and you watch them
what you find is we laugh with just with
other people it's something we're primed
to do with me around other people so
studies have found that we are thirty
three zero times more likely to laugh
there's somebody else with you then if
you're on your own and your laugh more
if you know that person or you like that
person it's kind of modulated by your
feelings for them so it's a very social
behavior so it's a social behavior but
do we laugh because it's it's funny
because we've got a sense of humor or is
it also other or the mechanisms
well sometimes you are laughing because
something's funny that humor definitely
exists but most of the time within
conversations people are laughing to
show that they agree they're loving to
show they know each other that they like
each other that they understand each
other so it's actually it's very
communicative we use laughter to do a
lot of the social communication in a
conversation where we're saying words
but we're also kind of showing that we
agree with each other and that we like
each other by actually laughing together
so so you have I mean you have a
receiver and you have a sender and
receiver right yeah what do you know
about that how do we react to laughter
how do we respond to it there's always a
sort of social appraisal about what's
going on there's some amazing research
coming out of America showing that if
you take couples and it's it's a
long-term study of people in married
relationships they take couples and they
put them in stressful situations and
they wire them up so you can see
people's bodies changing as they get
stressed and they hope they stress them
is they say to one member of the couple
tell me something that your wife does
that irritates you so just run that you
imagine how that kind of feels it it's a
stressful thing to have to do what they
find is both members of the couple get
stressed out by that because it's
unpleasant
it feels stressful what they find in
terms of the what happens next is the
couples who use laughter to deal with
that stressful situation not only become
less stressed but they are happier in
their relationship and they tend to stay
together for longer but only this
excludes the passive-aggressive laughter
right well it actually in this
situations we're just enough that you do
it
but what really counts is you both have
to do it so if one person's going yes it
is very irritating what I do and the
first person's going it's a massive
problem and I wish you'd stop no one
feels better because you said I changed
yeah and it was actually a couple of my
friends group of friends in Paris those
hilarious they're so funny they make me
laugh and they make fun of me and it was
one summer when I started laughing and I
couldn't stop laughing every time I was
with them and I changed that summer yeah
I know I changed they were making fun of
me and I was like so locked into my
serious bubble before and they totally
changed me but what is the hardest is it
to fake crying or is it a fake laughter
you can't fake love I think because in
films like you know if you just put some
testifed on whatever you you know it
looks like you're crying and people
think oh she's sad oh he said you know a
lot of factors kind of cheats with that
but laughing is like you would recognize
a fake laugh like straightaway
absolutely there's the communicative
laughs they are very very different from
spontaneous help helpless loves you you
can make sounds when you're laughing
helplessly you simply could not produce
voluntarily I've got a ridiculously high
pitch laugh and I could never sing that
high I can only get to that note when I
laughing what if I mean you study the
brain what if there's some kind of brain
damage some kind of change in the ring
how do you well those people respond to
that there's there's two kind of answers
to that so first of all it's not unusual
for really peculiar laughter and sort of
on involuntary laughter a lot of people
don't want to happen to be associated
with patterns of brain damage it can be
the first symptom of diseases like
Parkinson's disease can appear with a
really peculiar laugh that people can't
stop doing so if you look at the
literature there's not very much science
research into laughter but most of its
actually case studies of these peculiar
laughs that you can also find if you go
into bigger scale you know developmental
problems problems that somebody might
suffer over their whole life that's not
associated with the disease and we can
find laughter looking quite different
there so we did a study last year with
teenage boys who are at risk of becoming
Psychopaths so they're on a
developmental trajectory where they're
showing problems with their conduct
they're behaving badly and they also
have um but it's called they're high in
what are called social callous and
unemotional traits what this means is
they behave badly and they don't care
they don't care if they hurt you and we
were comparing them to teenage boys you
had conduct problems they were badly
behaved but didn't have this high in
callous and unemotional trait so these
boys they're not behaving in great but
they are not at risk of becoming
Psychopaths and what we find is the boys
who are at risk don't show contagious
laughter they don't join in and other
people laugh they don't find laughter
contagious and they don't show the
priming response that we can see in the
brain when you somebody hears laughter
you can see the brain getting ready to
join in because it's a really well-known
behavior and these boys don't show it
now I'm not saying psychopathy it's a
problem of laughter you don't know there
it's the classic problem you don't know
the direction of causation here so we
don't know if there's something that's
different about these boys from the
outset that means they don't learn to
laugh with other people or if the
experiences that they're having growing
up means they don't get the opportunity
to learn to laugh with other people but
it suggests that laughed is quite an
important thing to look at because it
takes you from somebody's emotional
world directly into their social
interactions because if you around
someone who doesn't join in with
laughter it's horrible and it's very
hard to feel like you're getting a
connection going it's a very important
part of being human definitely laugh but
but what about the animals do we do we
find laughter among the animals as well
it turns out a lot of people over time
have thought humans were the only
animals that laugh because Nietzsche
thought only man laughs because only
only man understands how awful life is
that it turns out the Apes are on to it
as well no way other Apes chimpanzees
gorillas orangutangs they love and it's
really really easy to recognize that
because it looks and often sounds just
like human laughter they even kind of
stopped pushing each other away and you
making a squeaking noise so it's it's
very very recognizable but then it also
turns out from working there in America
that rats laugh so these guys what makes
them laugh I mean across the board if
you're you have no idea we're taking
over this planet what you find is that
the across the board if you're a human
or another ape or a rat the thing that
gets laughter going initially is
tickling and rats are very ticklish nape
of the neck apparently likes if you need
to know this we need to tickle a rat
nape of the neck is where you need to go
just there they like it and they make
that sound when they're playing and when
they're tickling and we can't normally
hear it so you have to reduce the you
have to record the sounds they make and
then lower it so we can hear the sounds
and then you'll find I mean do you see a
smile or like how do the rat laugh they
make a sort of squeaking sound I know
that's probably not terribly scientific
sounding that's Sophie we know rats
squeak but they make a very specific
squeaking sound they don't make in any
other context the only other time they
make this sound when they're playing
with each other and they're very social
and playing is tickling and that's
university you should take a particular
try and get a game going I was going to
ask that what are we going to use this
research for the work with the rats is
really interesting because you can do
experiments with rats that you can't do
with humans so we know from the rats
that the more you tickle a baby rat the
more that rat will take laugh when it's
tickled at all laughs exactly so we know
that Laster reserved Psychopaths that
exactly and they are
optimistic so they will continue
pressing levers to get mean most people
they don't have rats at all but they do
have perhaps dogs yes we don't I
strongly suspect there is more laughter
out there we only know about the rats by
accident and the Apes because it's
obvious no one's really looking for it
but I suspect that because it's so
closely associated with play and all
mammals play that and in fact the man
who did the work with the rats says that
it's hard laughter is an invitation to
play come and do it let's do this fun
safe activity let's join together in the
island resources this yet all right well
we're trying with dogs because dogs are
a very good candidate for an animal that
plays throughout their whole lifetime
play it's really important to dogs and
we strongly suspect that there may not
be a sound associated with it or if
there is we can't normally hear it we're
starting with trying to look at how
bright how dogs listen to human laughed
in tourists perhaps they don't laugh
because I did some research on my own
yeah and so I'm a bit ahead of you
because I have a dog it's called Bruno
and this morning I knew you were coming
so I showed him some comedy okay
take take a take a look at this response
this is Bruno watching comedy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so it's very hard to get a lot this
happening it's over no more fun the
thing that probably is different about
humans is that we can laugh at things
that are distant from us so comedy on a
screen hearing something on the radio
you if you're an animal another animal
you laugh when you're tickled when
you're playing and that's very physical
it requires actual direct contact and
the laughter happens as a consequence of
that so what what about what about the
man with a poker face he laughs a lot he
does he does so you have you have a good
from time to time I think it's important
mm-hmm to be honest I mean I think in my
workplace I walk around a lot talking to
to the people I work with and if they
don't laugh I get really sad because
they're telling jokes oh no no no I'm
really bad at jokes it's just no I feel
the atmosphere the ambience is very
important yeah I've always you know
communicated with the people I work with
and and I'm always very happy and I
laugh a lot I didn't do when my
grandfather gave me my name but I am
doing today in your workshop when you
work after it's a big problem because a
lot of the students who come they try to
be you know the serious artist face
[Laughter]
that's just as much part of the training
it's learning them out to paint learning
them to get some humor to loosen up yeah
yeah yeah could you tell a joke that you
let's you can guarantee that always
works well with the proviso that no
science is exact I have to give you a
likelihood there is a 90% chance of
people will laugh okay
possibly and also that I am NOT in
Britain so this is this
it's bad it's cause of culture okay
that's why this bring justice and you
can't get the crowd so my dog is very
badly behaved he chases anyone on a
bicycle in fact it got so bad I had to
take his bicycle away hope you enjoyed
the clip for more interesting
conversations please hit subscribe